Guten Abend, mein Name ist Attakka. Ich bin hier zuständig erst in Pürsü.
Erst werde ich zu Ihrer Person angefragt.
Guten Abend, Herr Doktor.
Servus.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Franz Müller.
Franziska Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie?
Am 15. April 1988.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,75 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegeln Sie?
Das ist ein Problem.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit sehr viel zugenommen.
Ich habe ungefähr 85 kg.
Und ich habe ungefähr 10 kg zugenommen.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie?
94 kg.
In welcher Zeitraum haben Sie diese Gewicht zugenommen?
Also halb bis dreiviertel Jahr.
Also ungefähr acht, neun Monate.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarzt?
Das ist der Hans Huber.
Doktor Hans Huber.
Der ist in der Stadtmitte.
In der Ludwigstraße.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was fühlt Sie uns heute?
Ah, Frau Doktor.
Wie gesagt, ich fühle mich seit Monaten nicht so gut.
Mein Hausarzt ist jetzt in Urlaub.
Deswegen komme ich jetzt hierher zu Ihnen.
Ich kann sagen, seit einem Jahr habe ich zunehmende Schwäche,
Kraftlosigkeit.
Ich habe Gewicht zugenommen, obwohl ich ganz normal esse,
wie immer.
Ich kann schlecht schlafen.
Und meine Haut fühlt sich ganz schlimm an.
Das ist so richtig, als ob da viel Wasser drin wäre.
Teig ich fühlt sich das an.
Und meine Haare haben sich verändert, meine Finger nägel.
Also da ist irgendetwas, ich weiß nicht.
Und ich, wie gesagt, ich bin chronisch müde.
Ich verstehe, seit einem Jahr haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Also am Anfang war das jetzt nicht so auffällig.
Ich dachte, das geht wieder vorbei.
Vielleicht war ich ein bisschen überarbeitet.
Aber es wird nicht besser.
Im Gegenteil, es wird immer schlimmer.
Haben Sie Haarausfall?
Sie haben gesagt, ja.
Ja, genau, die Haare.
Besonders am Kopf?
Ja, am Kopf.
Ich habe das schon mal durch die Haare gekämmert.
Da kommen sie so büchelweise in die Hand.
Die sind auch so gebrechlich, die Haare gehen schnell kaputt.
Und so langsam mache ich mir Sorgen.
Ist Ihr Haut trocken?
Nee, eher nicht.
Er ist andersherum feucht.
Manchmal schwitze ich.
Sind Ihre Nägel brüchiger als sonst?
Ja, die Nägel sind auch ganz komisch.
Die werden brüchiger.
Da sind kleine Risse manchmal drin.
Haben Sie auch bemerkt, ist Ihre Stimme anders gelingt?
Nee, das jetzt nicht.
Aber ich merke das einfach, mein Hals.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass hier am Hals,
dass das ein bisschen größer geworden ist.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich Schluckbeschwerden habe,
dass mein Schlucken nicht so gut ist.
Irgendwie komisch.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen beim Schlucken?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, es ist irgendwie etwas um meinen Hals.
Also, ob ich einen Schal um den Hals hätte.
Und wenn ich meinen Kopf so ein bisschen strecke,
dann kommt so ein bisschen eine Vorwürbung raus.
Haben Sie auch Blesse bemerkt?
Sind Sie willass?
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Spüren Sie, dass Ihr Herz schneller oder langsamer schlägt?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass auch mein Herz schwach geworden ist.
Alles sehr langsam.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich keine.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen im irgendwelchen Körperregion bemerkt?
Ja, das ist mein Problem.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich etwas aufgedunnt bin,
dass ich aufgeschwollen bin oder aufgequollen.
Ich habe überall ein Gesicht an den Beinen im Bauchbereich.
Ich will so wie aufgeblasen zum Teil.
Es ist spannend so ein bisschen.
Das ist schon komisch.
Ramular, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich keine.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie schwitzen?
Ich schwitze öfters.
Das stehe manchmal nicht immer,
wenn ich meine Kleider oder mein T-Shirt wechseln.
Aber ich kann auch schlecht schlafen.
Früher konnte ich sofort einschlafen
und konnte ich auch durchschlafen.
Aber es fällt mir schwer,
einzuschlafen.
Aber ich werde immer wieder wach.
Das ist ein unruhiger Schlaf.
Haben Sie auch Konzentrationsstörung?
Ja, manchmal schon.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Gewicht zu genommen haben?
Ja.
Etwa 30 Kilogramm?
10 Kilogramm, nicht mehr.
Von 85 auf?
Entschuldige.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder bei dem Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe immer ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Aber manchmal habe ich Verstopfungsnahelung.
Da nehme ich auch etwas zum Abführen.
Das ist immer sehr wechselhaft.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Verstopfung?
Ich habe Tropfen, das sind Lachsoperaltropfen.
Wir helfen immer ganz gut.
Wenn ich zwei, drei Tropfen nehme, das hilft mir ganz gut.
Sie nehmen diese bei Bedarf nicht?
Ja, nicht richtig.
Haben Sie irgendwann eine Allergien oder unverträglichen Beide?
Nein, nein.
Leiden Sie und ihr könnt auch erkrankt werden.
Also bisher noch nicht.
Eigentlich war ich gesund und deswegen wundert mich das jetzt.
Arbeiter, wobei wie gesagt,
seit einem halben Jahr das Arbeiten mir auch schwer fällt.
Aber bisher habe ich nichts gehabt.
Keine Tablette, keine Erkrankungen.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Automechanikerin.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite in einer Werkstatt.
Ich repariere Autos.
Eigentlich ein Männerberuf, aber mir macht es Spaß.
Ich mache das auch gerne.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie keine Erkrankungen haben.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit krank
oder haben Sie wegen aktueller oder anderer Beschwördern
einen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, ich hatte jetzt zuletzt im Winter eine Erkältung.
Aber von vor vier Wochen angefangen.
Haben Sie einen Arzt aufgesucht wegen dieser Erkältung?
Ja, aber ich habe nur eine Krankmeldung gebraucht.
Also ich habe eine Erkältung gebraucht.
Sind Sie schon einmal offiziell gebraucht?
Nein, alles noch drin.
Nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Nur diese Lachsoperale bei Bedarf?
Ja.
Fraumüller raufen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe fast auch nicht.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie irgendwelche Kontakte
mit Drogen haben?
Nein, aber manchmal komme ich nur vor.
Ich bin so müde und so abgeschossen,
als ob ich Drogen genommen hätte.
Aber ich nehme keine Drogen.
Gleich brauch ich welche, die ich habe.
Ich empfehle nichts.
Sind Sie per Heurast?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Ein Sohn, der ist zehn Jahre alt und eine Tochter,
sie ist fünf.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Bitte schön.
Was sind Ihre Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Nicht, dass ich sie nicht müsste.
Mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck
und ein Problem mit seinem Brust-Tater.
Er hat sonst keine Beschwerden.
Meine Mutter hat keine Beschwerden.
Er hat keine Beschwerden.
Meine Mutter hatte mal kurzfristig
eine leichte Depression,
und hat Medikamente genommen.
Aber der geht es gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe auch zwei Geschwister.
Ein Bruder und eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Was haben Sie in Ihrer Frau und Arzt?
Ich war jetzt auch unregelmäßig.
Meine Frau meinte,
ich soll erst mal abwarten.
Ich hatte nichts Besonderes gemacht.
Was ist Ihre letzte Periode?
Ich habe vier Wochen.
Ich habe eine kleine Periode.
Sie haben auch Menstruationsbeschwerden.
Beschwerden hat keine Schmerzen,
aber es ist etwas unregelmäßig.
Ich verstehe nicht.
War es Ihnen nicht derzeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Sind Sie gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten
und Covid-19 geübt?
Ja.
Die Impfungen nehme ich sehr ernst.
Ich bin gegen die notwendigen und wichtigen Impfungen geimpft.
Frau Müller, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Wenn Sie mir behilflich sein können,
wäre ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Ich habe heute meine Frauenärztin Blutangel.
Der Termin ist erst in zwei Wochen.
Vielleicht können Sie mir etwas Blut abnehmen
und einige Untersuchungen vornehmen.
Ich möchte endlich mal wissen, was das Problem ist.
Ich verstehe ganz genau,
dass Sie den Grund Ihrer Beschwerden möglichst schnell wissen wollen.
Jetzt werden wir dann
auf die anderen Seite des Wortes
über die Erdenkrankheiten.
Wir werden verschiedene Tests durchführen.
Okay.
Alles klar. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Es gibt Fragen aus dem Auditorium
Ich höre mich meine Frau. Alles klar. Super.
Keine Frage. Gut. Dann gehen wir eine halbe Minute Pause für die Frau Doktor
und dann können wir gleich weitermachen.
Haben Sie bisher auf der Arbeit mit belastenden Schutralung zu tun?
Nein, bei uns gibt es keine Fragen.
Danke.
Bitte schön.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie jemanden mit einer stürzen Erkrankung?
Müste ich jetzt nicht. Nein. Danke.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt. Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine Patience vorstellen,
wie ich gerade eben in der Fotofnahme gesehen habe.
Sehr gut. Dann erzählen Sie mal, berichten mal.
Was haben Sie für den Patienten aufgenommen?
Frau Francis Camulet. Eine Patientin.
38 Jahre alt, 30 nicht, 40 Jahre alt. 175 cm groß, 74 kg schwer.
94 kg schwer.
94 kg. Davor sie war 85 kg.
Die Patientin stellt sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit etwa einem Jahr beste Hände,
Fatigue und Kraftlosigkeit.
Begleitend berichtet die Patientin über Gewicht,
zunahme etwa 10 kg innerhalb der dreiviertel Jahre
und dysphagie, hyperhydrosa, Haurausfall, besonders am Kopf,
Gesicht und Beine, Beine ödeme, Radikade, Onikorexis
und ein Globus für Impulse.
Was war das letzte, Onikorexis?
Onikorexis, Brühe, Gernei, Gölb.
Ah, okay, gut.
Die vegetative Anamnesi ist unafällig bis auf Schlagsstörung,
in Zominier in Form von Ein- und Durch- und Optipation.
Die Patientin fernahnte Irgendwerfererkrankungen
und Zine- und Medikamentere gelten ein.
Sie ist Niraoherin, Trinke, Zerzerthen-Alpohol
und fernahne Drogenkonsum.
Sie sei Auto-Mechanikerin als Beruf verheiratet
und habetsewei Gezündekinder.
Die Patientin hat ein
Interfamilien-Anamnesi dasselbe,
und sie hat eine Art der Hypertonie und eine Prostate-Hyperplasie,
und die Mutter hat eine Depression mit Medikamenten behandelt.
Die Patientin hat zwei Gezündekinder.
Die Patientin fügte auf Hinsu, dass sie unregenmäßiger Menstruation haben.
Diese sind alle aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich den Verdacht auf Hypotheose als
Diagnosen kommen, Anämie, Depression in Betracht.
Woran denken Sie noch? Haben wir Gynäkologen unter uns?
Eine Beginnende in der Menopause.
Sie hat ja noch einige Maßnahmen, aber sie hat Störungen, sie hat jegliche Symptome.
Auch daran muss man denken, sie hat das entsprechende Alter.
Woran denken wir noch?
Vielleicht können die Kollegen und Kolleginnen etwas behilflich sein oder Ideen einwerfen.
Nieren ist für Sie?
Sehr gut. Dieses aufgeschwollene, aufgequollene kann auch ein Zeichen von einem nephrotischen Syndrom sein.
Einfaches Vitamin-Mangel, Vitamin B12-Mangel, Vitamin D-Mangel.
Mir fällt auch nichts mehr ein.
Sehr gut.
Die Symptome sprechen für eine Hypotheose.
Anämie hat sich schon gesagt, für eine Hypotheose.
Und dementsprechend muss man schauen, welche Daborwerte man untersucht, welche Untersuchung diagnostisch macht man?
Wir gehen des Verdachts auf eine Hypotheose.
Ich werde zuerst eine Körperle unterzogen.
Dabei besonders achte ich auf Strom.
Ich nehme Blut ab. Aus dem Blut möchte ich kleines Blutbild, CRP, BSG und TSH, freies C3, C4.
Was noch von der Schildtröte zusätzlich?
Die Troidauto-Antikörper.
Was wollen Sie mich wissen?
Was kann eine Schildtröte unter Funktion machen?
Eine Schildtröte kann eine Autoräte machen.
Was ist das?
Antitroglöblin.
Magtaktrak.
Das sind die Antikörper.
Was bedeutet, wenn es zu viel oder zu wenig ist?
Autimun-Antikörper.
Sie sollten wissen, was das bedeutet, wenn die Ergebnisse zu viel oder zu wenig sind.
Was machen Sie mit der Schildtröte?
Ich mache eine Schildtröte auf Ultraschall.
Sehr gut.
Ein EKG würde ich noch machen?
Weil der Patient radikardee habe.
Eine Urinkontrolle würde ich machen.
Vorhin war die Frage mit einer Niereninsuffizie.
Und aus der Blut Elektrolyte.
Nierenwerte.
Eiweiß.
12.
Vitamin D.
Und die Morin würde sich dann zeigen, ob da eine Proteinurie ist.
Sehr gut.
Was machen Sie denn?
Jetzt haben Sie ein TSA von 35.
Ich verschreibe Altiroxin.
Ein Schildtröte präparat.
Aber ich weiß nicht, dass es so ist.
Ich weiß nicht.
Was ist da drin?
Schauen Sie nach.
Wo sind die 40 Leute?
Traut euch.
Keine da. Alles Neurologen.
Du bist der einzige, der spricht.
Was für ein String.
Okay.
Dann müssen Sie das machen.
Wir machen es weiter.
Im Verlauf der Patienten.
2-3 Wochen.
Das kann man auch machen.
Am Anfang kann man das Engmaschige kontrollieren.
Und später reicht das 4-6 Wochen.
Wenn es gut eingestellt ist, kann man dann auch erst später kontrollieren.
Aber das wird sich dann bauen.
Sie müssen ja die Dosis immer anpassen.
Am Anfang wird man hohe Dosierungen geben.
Wenn jemand so in eine unterfunktion ist,
auf der Intensivstation, haben wir auch Patienten jeden Tag
150, 150 Tage gegeben.
Aber das war Intensivstation.
Und jeden kontrolliert.
Manchmal muss man am Anfang hohe Dosen geben.
150, 200 Mikrogramm.
Und dann vielleicht einmal die Woche,
also im ambulanten Sektor kontrollieren
und entsprechend dann wieder die Dosis reduzieren,
dass sie nicht in eine Überfunktion kommen.
Warum habe ich jetzt in Bayern
eine Hypertoriosi gedacht?
Was haben wir vergessen?
Was war ein Mangel herrscht?
Überwiegend in Bayern.
Wenn die wenig Fisch essen, wenn sie nicht am Meer sind.
Was fehlt meistens?
Ein Jodemangel.
Manchmal auch.
Sehr gut.
Okay, dann danke ich Ihnen, Frau Doktor.